so Mario just turned 30 and while that's
very exciting and you should definitely
go reminiscing about your childhood
Mario memories I thought we should also
chat about one of the less commonly
discussed aspects of everybody's
favorite plumber the fact that he's a
total jerk there's a good chance that
Mario would not have been told that
close to Peter back in the day as it
seems that whole animal rights movement
thing is not all that close to his heart
as uncovered by game series matpat Mario
kicks off his reign of animal abuse in
1984 as Donkey Kong circus from the game
and watch gallery the Donkey Kong
prequel shows Mario and then referred to
as jump man laughing at the Apes of
failing at juggling pineapples and
watching him get scorched by falling
fireballs he's also a mega [ __ ] in
Donkey Kong jr. wherein the little
monkey needs to try and save his caged
up dad from the whip-wielding plumber on
top of that he's shown a pretty massive
distaste for wigglers and cheep cheeps
among the Mushroom Kingdom other
inhabitants neither of these guys are
all that interested in hurting Mario but
he destroys their homes burns them to
bits and stops them to death anyway I
mean in Super Mario Sunshine a wiggler
wakes up on the wrong side of the bed
inconveniencing the hatching of a
Standford and Mario decides the best
solution is to force him to topple onto
his back so he can crush it in its soft
belly and kill it
not cool Mario the abuse doesn't stop
there though Mario's also a dick to his
family members and closest friends his
buddy or she might not actually be a
blood family member but given how much
time he spends helping out Mario he goes
through a lot of crap Yoshi gets smacked
in the back of the head and dropped into
pits of death in order to help Mario
take out enemies and jump higher while
his brother Luigi is constantly
relegated to second fiddle Luigi is
expected to tag along and helped rescue
Mario's girlfriend who he does a real
poor job of keeping track of despite
Luigi
and admiration for his brother which you
can see in his secret diary entries in
painful Mario Luigi rarely gets the
recognition and reciprocation he craves
and when he finally gets his own game
it's the bloody edutainment title where
Luigi needs to think about geography of
all things the next time they give him a
shot the poor guy sent into a haunted
house with nothing but a vacuum cleaner
to get the ever-loving [ __ ] scared out
of him
way to have your birds back Mario
there's also been some speculation over
whether Mario is helping or hurting the
Mushroom Kingdom strapped toads
the Super Mario Brothers guidebook
explains that bounder turned a whole
heap of defenseless codes into blocks
gas it around the kingdom if you've ever
played a Mario game you probably
remember Mario breaking blocks left
right and centre since that's kind of
his thing what we can take away from
this is that Mario is not only murdering
these toads turned blocks he's raiding
their bodies I mean money and power-ups
fall out of their corpses if those
blocks are indeed traps toads as the
game manual suggests that's pretty damn
messed up Mario all in all it seems that
Mario is just one of those guys that
wants to watch the world burn sure he's
out there to save the Mushroom Kingdom
from Bowser but much like the world
saving antics of the Avengers the place
gets kind of busted up in the process
Mario makes his way through the kingdom
pillaging every coin in resource incite
and killing off the inhabitants both
violent and innocent
I guess he figures as long as he picks
up his lady in the final castle even
though he'll inevitably lose her again
by the next game it's all good we'll
always love Mario for shaping our
childhoods but it probably doesn't hurt
to realize that like many of our loved
ones he can be a real dick at times let
me know down in that comment section
what you think of Mario and I will catch
you again next week